[Música]
Bienvenidos a Francia enfoco este 2 de
abril se conmemoró el Día Mundial para
la concientización sobre el autismo
autismo un problema común pero con poca
soluciones fue el lema elegido por
autismo Francia la mayor asociación de
padres
Porque si bien este síndrome que se
caracteriza por una alteración de las
facultades comunicativas y sociales
afecta a uno de cada cien franceses los
padres se quejan de diagnósticos tardíos
y lentos y de una insuficiente
escolarización y acompañamiento
profesional ser padre de un niño autista
en Francia todavía un camino de
sacrificio de buena voluntad y
experimentación
este espontáneo entre Gabriel de casi
cuatro años y su madre rim hace un año y
medio era impensable el niño nació con
un trastorno del espectro autista que le
fue diagnosticado en la guardería en
plena pandemia
nos recomendaron consultar al comienzo
uno otorrino porque pensaban que quizás
era sordo porque no respondía cuando lo
llamaban Luego fuimos a ver a la
neuropediatra que nos dijo directamente
el diagnóstico su hijo tiene problemas
del espectro autista en un principio la
joven pareja tocó todas las puertas y
recibieron la respuesta básica en
Francia se les asignó un pedo psiquiatra
que veía al niño una vez cada dos
semanas
y nos dijimos que teníamos una suerte
increíble porque tuvimos muy rápido un
cupo en un centro médico psiquiátrico
casi dos meses después de pedirla Y eso
que nos habían dicho que normalmente
había que esperar años pero claramente
no es suficiente porque continuaba en la
guardería y debía entrar a la escuela
Aunque en Francia muchos niños autistas
van a colegios tradicionales con el
acompañamiento de un cuidador la
terapeuta recomendó a rim y ciril Buscar
un método más intensivo para el pequeño
en Francia teníamos una tendencia a ser
muy rígidos en los enfoques se necesita
tiempo para lanzar cosas nuevas para mí
es un tema de Educación global Hay un
problema en nuestro sistema una rigidez
no me imagino ver a Gabriel sumergido
entre muchos niños y no poder tener una
atención
la profesional les recomendó el método
tresi aunque no tiene el reconocimiento
de la alta autoridad de la salud Eso no
fue freno para la joven familia
hay tratamientos muy diversos los unos
de los otros pero a mí me dio la
sensación de que lo iban a encerrar con
otros niños como él y nada más entonces
averigüé sobre este método dice la
formación y directamente me llamó la
atención es un desarrollo por el juego
uno sigue el niño uno entra en su ritmo
y lo dejamos llevarnos a su mundo y uno
intenta entrar en su mundo para decirle
que estamos aquí que queremos jugar con
él y poco a poco el niño se abre a jugar
con el otro y esa es formidable y es que
Gabriel hace un año jugaba solo siempre
siempre alejaba a la gente se daba
vuelta y ni siquiera respondía Cuando
uno lo llamaba por su nombre
cada día de nueve de la mañana 5 de la
tarde Gabriel asiste a este centro donde
una veintena de voluntarios se turnan
para jugar con él si uno falla la
familia debe asegurar el relevo el
jueves la última hora y media Es Pascal
está jubilada quien juega con Gabriel
[Música]
siempre al comienzo de la sesión después
de la siesta es así él se columpia nos
quedamos un rato así pero luego desde
hace un tiempo el mismo me pasa los
juguetes por ejemplo los ratoncitos para
que intercambiemos para que Juguemos
el Instituto la ha formado brevemente
Aunque gran parte de lo que ocurre en la
habitación de Gabriel viene de la
intuición de Pascal que ve claramente un
progreso en el pequeño
él es muy ingenioso es capaz de tomar el
tobogán ponerlo de lado y hace un
circuito para los autos y jugamos a eso
[Música]
Gabriel tiene uno de los cinco cupos que
hay en el centro Pero cientos de padres
aplican el método en sus casas
estaba de buen humor hace tiempo que no
jugábamos a los autos
sueñan con ver al pequeño en el colegio
pero lo enviarán cuando consideren que
está listo al menos dentro de tres años
cuando complete este método
[Música]
para unos es el juego para otros la
danza lo que les hace conectar con los
demás hace cinco años que la practica
gianna esta niña de 15 años con un
trastorno del espectro autista
el comienzo estaba en un curso exclusivo
para personas con discapacidad mentales
pero Melanie la profesora pensó que
gianna podía integrarse a un curso
ordinario
al cabo de un año me di cuenta que
gillana podía memorizar un ejercicio una
coreografía copiar a los otros ella
aprende la musicalidad como uno se
desplaza en una gran sala y como uno se
sitúa en una sala la danza permite
desarrollar su conciencia corporal su
conciencia con respecto al espacio y al
otro salud
y la alegría Es evidente cuando le toca
moverse
[Música]
danza pero también los miércoles cuando
no hay clases en Francia giana va a un
centro de la juventud de su comuna
la familia ha aprovechado todas las
instancias públicas disponibles
escribieron hasta el presidente para
tener toda la ayuda posible
hicimos muchos trámites escribimos al
menos 200 Cartas certificadas al
presidente los ministros alcaldes y
hasta fuimos recibidos por la agencia de
salud
de pequeña fue una escuela para niños
neurotípicos es decir una escuela
ordinaria y preadolescente asiste a un
centro especial que está dentro de un
colegio tradicional sus padres han
exigido que no se le dé ningún
medicamento que es algo que se suele
criticar a estos centros
no se nota que tiene una minusvalía
porque es un trabajo largo que hemos
realizado si no lo hacemos Nadie lo hará
por nosotros Incluso si hay profesiones
que nos ayudan y nosotros queremos que
llegue lo más lejos posible porque tiene
las capacidades y nosotros le damos los
medios para conseguirlo
en la casa de Diana sus hermanas también
juegan un rol importante yana de 13 y yo
Eli de ocho la desafían en los juegos de
mesa Aunque más de una vez es ella quien
gana
Hola acompañan en esta Pasión por la
música y la danza que le saca sus
mejores sonrisas
[Música]
Pero cuál es la situación que vive los
adultos con un síndrome del espectro
autista cuando buscan trabajo veamos el
siguiente reportaje
[Música]
claris está especialmente nerviosa este
día jueves después de haber cursado una
licenciatura en lenguas y un máster en
idiomas aplicados al comercio
internacional Busca un trabajo de verano
antes de retomar los estudios el próximo
año
para eso ha venido a este salón donde le
han organizado cuatro entrevistas de
trabajo
[Música]
lo coordina
la inserción en el trabajo y estudios de
personas con discapacidad en Francia las
empresas de más de 20 empleados están
obligadas a que un 6% del personal tenga
alguna minusvalía
necesito Claridad en las instrucciones
si es por escrito mejor evitar hablar
con gestos y cuidar el tono de la voz
porque quizás no comprendo Lo que se
dice en el sentido adecuado también
tengo un casco reductor de ruido por si
es un sitio bullicioso
Explica lo que necesita para adaptarse a
un ambiente laboral de manera armónica
hace un año le diagnosticaron un
trastorno del espectro autista
la detección tardía es frecuente
yo tengo una minusvalía invisible
siempre viví sin entender lo que me
pasaba mis dificultades comenzaron
cuando estaba en la universidad una
fatiga intensa sin comprender Por qué
muy emotiva con reacciones que parecían
desproporcionadas con respecto a lo
normal y con dificultades para entender
las emociones de la gente
la mayoría de los jóvenes que tienen un
trastorno autista ligero es decir
aquellos que logran seguir estudios
superiores muchas veces de manera
brillante dura muy poco en el trabajo el
mundo laboral no entiende sus
dificultades de comunicación ni su
extrema sensibilidad
hay empresas
donde han empleado a varios practicantes
y un joven en contrato indefinido con
esta minusvalía
preparado para adaptarse a este tipo de
trabajadores
[Música]
la principal cualidad de estos
trabajadores es la seriedad siempre Irán
hasta el final de las cosas son
cuidadosos en el trabajo lo terminan y
son organizados la mayoría de las veces
aunque esto cambia obviamente de persona
en persona
[Música]
una cosa importante a mostrar cuando uno
está en entrevistas al entusiasmo pero
es entusiasmo no se ve muy seguido usted
tendrá adelante a alguien que parece no
querer el trabajo aunque es Quizás lo
único que sueña para facilitar el empleo
de personas con algún trastorno del
autismo la asociación antisuv forma
previamente a las empresas
son personas que no saben expresar
emociones porque no ponen entonación ni
usan gestos que no saben servirse de su
cuerpo de su cara y paralelamente no
saben interpretar eso en otras personas
florian habla con propiedad el mismo fue
diagnosticado de un trastorno autista
Ligero en 2011 como a muchos se le
despertó la universidad diez años antes
pero en ese momento lo trataron por
esquizofrenia
[Música]
en la universidad nos piden ser
autónomos en el trabajo usted tiene una
residencia estudiantil ya no tiene más
la referencia de su casa sus padres ya
no le hacen de comer ya no tiene
personas con quién relacionarse Usted
debe dominar este nuevo mundo pero eso
no viene naturalmente yo no lo conseguí
el tiempo era lento el tiempo solo el
social también porque si mis compañeros
me proponían salir yo tenía siempre algo
que hacer que no era real y mi cerebro
Me pedía cada vez más y yo caí en
depresión fobia social y tenía cada vez
más pensamientos suicidas en esa época
[Música]
siete años después es uno de los
empleados asalariados de la asociación
está casado tiene una hija y aunque
considera que su camino de inserción es
exitoso sabe que aún no está terminado
y hasta aquí este capítulo de Francia
enfoco Muchas gracias por habernos
acompañado y hasta una próxima por las
pantallas de France 24 o en France
24.com